-There's a thing that happened
over the weekend in Iowa
that went viral.
A person came up to talk to you,
and it was very --
it was an emotional moment,
and I just want to show a clip
of that, if you don't mind.
-Sure.
-Check this out.
-Hi. My name is Raelyn.
-Hi, Raelyn.
-I was wondering if there was
ever a time in your life
where somebody you really looked
up to, [Voice breaking] um --
maybe didn't accept you as much,
and how you dealt with that.
-My mother and I
had very different views...
of how to build a future.
[ Voice breaking ] You just
got to do what's right inside
and...hope that maybe
the rest of the world
will come around to it.
And maybe they will,
and maybe they won't.
The truth is, you got to
take care of yourself first
and do this.
Give me a hug.
-Oh. Oh.
[ Applause ]
-That was emotional.
That went all over the place.
What made you guys connect?
What made you emotional there?
-You know, I could see her face.
-Aww.
-And as she started
this question,
I knew that she was in
the middle of something tough.
-Yeah.
-Someone she respected,
who wasn't -- didn't approve
of what she was --
where she was.
And you know, a lot of people
don't know,
I dropped out of school at 19,
got married to someone my mother
wanted me to marry.
And when Raelyn started to speak
it's, like, all of a sudden,
I was back on the phone
with my mother,
trying to explain
that after these years,
he had walked out
and he wasn't coming back.
-That's tough.
-And I knew how
she would feel about that.
-Yeah.
-Did your mom ever come around?
-[ Sighs ]
You know, we got back
together over it.
It was okay, but it is --
sometimes you just got to
do what's right.
-Yeah, that was great.
It's those moments like that,
that they're kind of unexpected,
obviously unplanned, but
you must go to so many campaigns
and kind of answer
the same questions.
But something like that,
does that re-energize you?
-You know, for me, it's --
I do selfie lines.
So, I get that one-on-one,
and you know,
I don't do big-dollar
fundraisers at all.
-Yeah.
-I don't go suck up
to billionaires
and corporate executives.
I've won my campaign
entirely with people
who pitch in
20 bucks and 5 bucks.
And I get to call those people.
In fact, if anyone goes
to elizabethwarren.com tonight
and pitches in 5 bucks
on the campaign or more,
tomorrow I will make calls
to people to say "Thank you,"
because I think that's
how democracy ought to work.
-Wow. Really?
-Yeah.
-Get right on the phone
and talk to them?
-Oh, yeah.